Ah yes, it’s that time of year again, and
nothing says holiday like freshly marked-down
merchandise!
The 40’s, the 50’s, the 60s PERCENT sales
on popguns, bicycles, roller skates, and kales!
Checkerboards, tricycles, popcorns, or pinwheels?
Or... do you just love you some deals?
I’m sure we’ve all been there, boasting
about how amazing that deal was and how much
money we saved on that 52 inch T.V. or pair
of shoes.
It happens to the best of us.
But is it the new gadget that makes you happy?
Or the great deal… because Kit Yarrow, a
consultant and consumer psychologist says
it’s the latter.
She says, customers are caring all too much
about the price of an item instead of valuing
the item itself.
Before 2008, stores naturally put items on
sale at the end of a season, but now?
There are sales through every single part
of the year: 4th-of-July sales, semi-annual
sales, weekly sales.
You name it.
There’s a bargain to be hunted.
Stores changed the psychology of shopping
when they appealed to the cheaper needs of
patrons during the recession.
And one Nielsen survey shows, some people
like the “hunt” for a bargain
And researchers say shopping a sale can trigger
the same parts of the brain as love or drugs.
The mere action of walking into a store can
get your dopamine levels going, but much like
a real addict, you go home with feelings of
guilt, because like maybe you didn’t need
that game console, even tho it was $100 off
and you sort of wanted it…ish.
Shopping increases activity in your nucleus
accumbens-- the reward circuit of your brain.
You anticipate purchases, and get excited
about them, and (according to one study) “excessive
prices … activate circuits associated with
anticipated loss.”
But a sale?
That’s a whole different thing.And stores
know this.
Yarrow suggests there’s a greater chance
of a person buying a product if they feel
like they’ve saved, and can walk away with
satisfaction at their bargain.
Even if the product is marked-up and then
the price is cut; you’re still happy because
you believe you saved, Mom!
Basically, these sale prices are trying to
convince you you're spending less than you
are.
But that’s not actually so.
Don’t let them fool you.
Next time you go shopping, try paying attention
to your emotions about the PURCHASE not the
DEAL.
You know, check yourself, before you wreck
your credit card statement.
Hey there deal seekers, why don’t you take
a moment and subscribe, doesn’t cost a thing.
I know I got fooled into it, but wanna know
how videos games trick you into spending real
money on fake stuff?
Julian has that for you here, Funny thing,
bargain shopping can be passed down, so my
Mom’s love of a good deal probably corrupted
me too!
Just pay attention, you’ll be fine.